[Música]
Olá é muito bom estar contigo novamente
está cansado de sentir falta de energia
descubra como o limão pode transformar
sua saúde além de ser barato fácil de
encontrar tem benefícios
surpreendentes tem um aroma revigorante
que já melhora o seu humor é recomendado
para pacientes em geral mas tomando
cuidados Ness necessários ele aumenta os
níveis de vitamina C é um suco natural
que tem a preservação dessa vitamina
geralmente sem muitos problemas de
perder as propriedades benéficas um
limão fornece metade da vitamina C
diária necessária para você a vitamina C
é muito importante porque ela é um
antioxidante ela melhora a imunidade ela
participa da formação do colágeno
diminui o sangramento das gengivas
protege os vasos sanguíneos e previne
pequenos vasos sanguíneos na pele Além
disso ácool Limão tem vários
fitonutrientes poderosos um deles é a
naringina que tem propriedades
antibacteriana antiviral e
antifungica tem também potencial no
auxílio ao tratamento complementar da
doença de alzheimer conta aqui para mim
se você tem alguém na sua família com
essa terrível do doença e não deixe de
assistir os meus vídeos sobre isso eu
vou deixar o link na descrição e no
primeiro comentário Além disso aqu Limão
tem uma propriedade incrível de Reduzir
a gordura do seu fígado vai combater
então a esteatose hepática que é o
excesso de gordura no fígado melhora o
fluxo de bile e remove excesso de
gorduras do seu organismo auxilia na
perda de peso reduzindo a resistência à
insulina vai combater também o seu
envelhecimento tem estudos de animais
mostrando que houve aumento de
longevidade com o uso da água com limão
Além disso temos benefícios para a
microbiota do intestino as bactérias
boas que te ajudam na sua saúde vai
prevenir a formação de pedra nos seus
rins por quê Porque o ácido cítrico
presente na fruta neutraliza oxalatos e
assim vai prevenir a formação das Pedras
ou cálculos renais a Além disso inibe a
formação do Câncer por quê Porque o
limão tem propriedades que combatem o
crescimento de células malignas
especialmente de língua pulmões e
intestino grosso bem como escolher o
melhor limão para você consumir Tem
vários tipos de limão o limão siciliano
é o que tem Casca Grossa e amarelada ele
é mais ácido e menos suculento o limão
Taiti ele tem uma casca fina é mais
arredondado menos áo e rico e vitamina C
o limão galego é mais arredondado e
suculento com uma casca verde clara o
limão cravo é pequeno suculento tem uma
casca alaranjada com nervuras como
escolher um bom limão para sua água
conta para mim aqui embaixo se você
encontra com facilidade essas variedades
que eu acabei de des escrever na região
onde você mora então dicas para escolher
é importante você escolher o limão que
tem a casca fina casca brilhante e Lisa
isso vai indicar o quê que é um produto
é um limão é uma fruta com mais suco
prefira Limões maduros evitando os
verdes e duros opte por Limões orgânicos
Se for possível para evitar consumo de
pesticidas de
agrotóxicos como consumir esse limão
principal delas você já deve imaginar
água com limão adicione o suco de um
limão em um copo de água e tome isso uma
vez ao dia evite excesso porque muitas
pessoas vão ter desconfortos gástricos
ou digestivos ao consumir esse limão e
você você sente queimação quando consome
limão conta aqui nos comentários outra
forma de consumir o limão muito legal é
consumir limão no chá
adicione depois que o chá esfria para
preservar a vitamina C e as catequinas
Então não coloque esse limão no chá
ainda quente espere resfriar quais são
outras combinações saudáveis você pode
combinar com vinagre de maçã tema de
outro vídeo recente então você pode
misturar 30 ml de suco de limão uma
colher de sopa de vinagre de maçã e 250
ml de água para ajudar a limpar o seu
fígado adicione gengibre ou canela para
ainda aumentar os benefícios Quais são
os cuidados que deve tomar então ao
consumir o limão prote os seus dentes
cuidado com o esmalte do os seus dentes
consuma antes escovar os dentes enxague
a boca com água pura após o consumo com
a água com limão para evitar de
desgastar então a camada dos seus dentes
escova os dentes meia hora depois de
tomar essa água com limão e quem deve
evitar o consumo de álcool limão evite
se você tiver candid dias de repetição
ou síndrome fungica até você resolver
essa condição depois que você resolveu o
candidíase ou a cum fúndica pode voltar
a consumir e consulte o seu médico se
você tiver gastrite antes de tomar a sua
água com limão que pode piorar em
algumas circunstâncias gostou dessa dica
então Salve E compartilhe com alguém que
você ama alguém que precisa cuidar da
sua saúde de forma mais natural
compartil os
vos
[Música]
aém tamb no
canal AL
você é fera um grande abraço e um beijo
no seu coração